so one of the most interesting micro
stories or sort of like sub stories of
the entire trump being banned from
twitter
and parlor being kicked off at the apple
store is the story of republican senator
josh hawley's
book so i'm going to kind of catch
everybody up quickly
if we're not all on the same page the
story won't make a lot of sense
so the meat of the story is as follows
republican senator josh hawley
got a lot of attention before january
6th
and he got an atta boy from donald trump
because josh hawley was the first
republican
senator to say he would be objecting to
the electoral vote count on january 6.
there had been a number of members of
the house of representatives who had
said
we will object i will object but for the
objections to actually stop the count
and lead to the two hours of debate that
normally would would take place
you also need a senator to object and
josh hawley
was the first senator to say i will be
objecting
cut to january 6th and we have a violent
insurrection
led by trumpists and after they were
able to re-secure
the capitol building later on january
6th and they reconvened josh hawley kept
going with his objections and his bogus
arguments about the election
so as a result of that josh hawley lost
a business opportunity
book publisher simon schuster decided
they don't want to have anything to do
with josh hawley anymore and they said
we are backing out of the book deal that
we had made with josh hawley now
remember simon schuster is a company
that exists in the united states meaning
they get to decide who they work with
they get to decide what book they
publish it's not the government
if the government got to decide what
book simon and schuster published
we would be more like a country with
centralized control of industry some
might call them communist countries we
would not be
what we are if anybody were able to tell
simon and schuster you must publish josh
hawley's book
well josh hawley went on tucker
carlson's program last night
and they both seem to not understand how
capitalism works all of a sudden let's
get into it
senator thanks so much for coming on so
there you're now one of the most
despised
people in america so i appreciate you're
taking the time for being hated to come
on the show tonight
but i want to ask you specifically about
what happened between you and simon and
schuster and i should say i published
with simon schuster i have a book
contract for a
future book with simon schuster it's
making me very uncomfortable watching
what they did
to you and what ground should they
cancel your book contract
so let's even stop there just for a
moment tucker says now
he himself is uncomfortable because he
has an upcoming book deal with simon
schuster well you know what tucker
you can act on that you can deal with
that if you're uncomfortable with what
simon and schuster did
you have the power to say to simon and
schuster i don't want to do the book
with you anymore
i'm going to find some right wing
publisher or whatever the case may be
that's how capitalism works if tucker
decides i'd rather not work with simon
schuster i'd rather not accept the money
he can say to them i'm out
let's continue well they don't like the
exercise of free speech tucker i think
is at the end of the day i mean this is
really about the first amendment it's
really about free speech
and simon schuster that didn't like me
doing what democrats in congress did in
2001 and 2005 and 2017
when democrat members of congress
objected during the certification
process in order to try to have a debate
about election integrity you know that's
the first amendment at work that's
democracy at work but
simon and schuster unfortunately a lot
of people on the left now decided that
the first amendment is something that
they no longer support and i'll just say
this tucker
at a time of division we've got to rally
around the things that
unites us as americans and i think the
first amendment of free speech
has got to be at the top of that list so
this is not about the first amendment
why why do they keep talking about the
first amendment josh hawley has a
right as a lawmaker it's not really even
about speech
as a senator josh hawley can object to
votes
on the grounds he objected to them simon
and schuster as a corporation
that exists in the united states can
decide we want to publish a book with
josh hawley or we don't that's it
that's the full story here josh hawley
is wrong that this is about the first
amendment or about free speech
and he also either forgets or doesn't
know or pretends not to know
that even if it were a free speech issue
freedom of speech doesn't mean
freedom from the consequences of that
speech speech has consequences it's
called capitalism
which they support tucker then also
appears not to get it
so if some polis some creepy low iq
politician says i want to shut down the
other side okay i get it
but a publisher is literally the
guardian of the first amendment
if you're a publisher you exist because
of the first amendment your duty is to
protect the first amendment
but the people around simon schuster are
now so crazed with ideology that they
can't bear to hear a country view
expressed i mean what what does that
pretend for the country well i think it
really shows sucker that we're in a
period where
the first amendment values and
principles of freedom of speech
also freedom of worship freedom of
religion these things are are really
under attack by some quarters by many
quarters that is not
at all what this is about this has
nothing to do with simon and schuster
wanting to suppress
speech or not being willing to hear a
different opinion
simon and schuster made a business
decision josh hawley
is a disgusting depraved extremist
agitator
his actions on january 6 confirm it
simon and schuster decided
you know the the books we would sell by
doing this book with josh hawley
for us don't outweigh the downside to
our business
of working with him and they made a
decision how can anyone argue against
simon schuster's unilateral right to
make that decision
now if simon and schuster said we refuse
to publish books by or employ
black people whoa hold on a second now
we're violating non-discrimination laws
that would be a very different story but
simon and schuster simply said we we
don't want to do business with someone
and holly goes to the first amendment
here take a look
and again i come back to the fact that
this is something the first amendment is
something that unites us
as americans and in this time of
division in this time of chaos we've got
to
we've got to stand strong for that if
you're wondering why
when reporters go to trump rallies and
they interview people
the people start talking about this is a
first amendment violation and that's a
first amendment violation and this
violated my free speech or trump's free
speech
this is why they are bombarded
constantly
with people who either don't understand
or are deliberately lying to them
about what is a free speech issue what
is
a first first amendment issue when it
has nothing to do
with that whatsoever so you know i
every time i ask this a bunch of people
say tucker definitely knows this is not
really about speech
josh hawley probably also knows they're
being disingenuous
that maybe that may be it doesn't matter
why they're doing it
it's bamboozling a lot of people and
again
it goes back to education and media
literacy if more people
were better educated they wouldn't fall
for this nonsense about this being an
issue of speech
let me know what you think so it's a new
year
and for many people that means new goals
around getting fit or losing weight and
if part of that for you
involves a low carb or ketogenic diet
then i have something you will want to
check out it's called
so keto-licious and they're giving you
20
off soaky delicious has perfected
ketogenic crusts for baking your
favorite foods
they make a delicious keto dessert crust
which comes in a chocolate and
vanilla flavor and it's perfect for
making things like pies they also have a
premium keto pizza crust which i've been
using at home to make pizzas and it's
great
it is great to go right out of the
freezer
and when you cook it it doesn't fall
apart like a lot of other low carb
crusts do it's high fat which is perfect
for keto
grain free gluten free no soy or
additives or preservatives or fillers
but most importantly
they just taste great i can tell you
firsthand just go to davidpakman.com
pizza the link is underneath this video
and they'll give you 20
off your entire order when you use the
coupon code pacman